laly's angels leads it and is great
pleasure for me to see that santini 6
michael freilich is country on its way
to its target orbit following his
success soulanges a major the chairman
of his forces
all the things to meet this very
important milestone this despite the
core i3 this we have been racing in
response
the command friend is a particle in
zurich agency for successful deployment
of this light and training and visign for
clearly to a qualification in cros
coordination with you pay and partners
this doctor jazz at which will be
operating six nations
would you like to highlight the industry
is a light was built enders au
leadership urbaine companies and media
company is such as the prime contractor
defense and space and the man in the
wood manufacture
thales alenia space network of the end
of companies including without  which is
mission would not be possible
monday archos 5 american by nasa anna
providing together with a industries khi
contri  bution to this long standing
transatlantic re operation example filed
by two days successfull launch of the
sands 6 7 et ride
ce soir m6 michel will bring boss
immediate and long-term profits 3 6
ghz providing the month of the sea level
of the ice possible
santana  6 is designed to act as the
world wide reference in motion
altimetry for the next weekend
i felt the six missions and sancho
copenhagen offers copernicus as the
europeans success company that
supports governance of the environment
by providing timely quality date to
training ring services  lège
in this capacity writes contributes to the
european green say a roof over the
economies and the digital world
they like them who all roll she
looks at the planet will do to future
generations
we need copernicus phase retour must
increase d'haguenau this would
copernicus at the tools for  monitoring
the effectiveness of the moon is we play
win it copernicus because we need the
data we can't ge  t to understand how to
be together in cooperation with all
about the first one bing and ios to this
demonstrator of deposits in dc1
british open in strategic flop
autonomy and independence and strong
bot system open to international
cooperation fifth match for making
this mission success